mesdames et messieurs bonsoir entre
dimanche dernier aujourd'hui le
thermomètre a fait des siennes en
moyenne des températures ont baissé de
12 à 14 degrés la météo pour demain que
je vous donnerai enfin l'édition n'est
pas particulièrement réjouissante elle
non plus il continuera à faire fiscaux
dont au sommet de notre édition une mise
en garde l'iran ou 9 de la communauté
européenne
si ceux ci prenait des sanctions et ce
dans une interview exclusive pour
antenne 2 en politique française le
comité central du rpr qui a réaffirmé
son attachement à la participation et
monsieur mitterrand au club de la presse
sports brillante victoire de bernard
hinault enfin on attendait dans liège
bastogne liège et un tiercé 12 9 3 avec
dans l'ordre un rapport de plus de 26
mille francs pour 130 nous commencerons
par les nouvelles venues de l'iran le
gouvernement de téhéran a démenti les
informations selon lesquelles les otages
de l'ambassade des états unis ne
seraient pas libérés avant les
présidentielles américaines
c'est à dire en novembre le débat sur
leur sort se déroulera au parlement
iranien nouvellement élu et ce au début
de juillet ce soir en tout cas
washington a interdit aux familles des
otages de se rendre en iran à téhéran
même le conseil de la révolution à
fermer les universités pour trois jours
afin de permettre au calme de revenir
après les affrontements qui se sont
produits toute la journée d'hier entre
groupes politiques extrémistes et qui
ont fait de nombreuses victimes
ainsi dans le quartier sud de terrain il
ya eu de violents accrochages entre
étudiants d'une part et religieux
intégriste d'autre part ceux ci ont
occupé dans la nuit le centre d'art
dramatique de la capitale mais ce soir
sur l'insistance du conseil de la
révolution ils ont annoncé qu'ils
l'évacuer
marthe tous ces événements interviennent
à la veille de la réunion à luxembourg
des ministres des affaires étrangères et
neuf pays de la communauté rencontre
préparatoire au sommet des chefs d'état
et de gouvernement des nefs qui aura
lieu dimanche et lundi prochain et ce
sera là une réunion très importante car
les neuf pourrait-il décider de
sanctions appliquées à dire hier
monsieur françois poncet disait par
exemple s'il faut prendre des sanctions
maintenant au plus tard je crois que les
neuf les prendrons mais l'iran les
mettant en garde contre une telle
décision dans une interview exclusive
accordé à bernard benyamin par monsieur
amiral haye ambassadeur d'iran à paris
il la donne alors que son ministre des
affaires étrangères monsieur date zabé
vient de passer 48 heures à paris où il
a travaillé pour parvenir à une détente
dans la crise irano-américaine les
décisions que les occidentaux d'une
frange contre l'iran c'est dicté par les
américains et des occidentaux savent
bien que leur intérêt propre aussi est
en jeu puisque nous nous avons le moyen
d'une solution aussi économiquement
enfin je ne peux pas citer tout le
détail nous nous avons en main aussi des
retours sion contre eux
n'est ce pas une vision besoin de nous
question du pétrole de cette question du
contrat et sera donc nous pouvons dans
leur part également
n'est ce pas nous avons des sanctions
c'est contre eux pensez vous monsieur
l'ambassadeur qu'un pays européens
oui ou autres pourraient jouer un rôle
déterminant
oui c'est ça j'ai compris oui bien sûr
ça cela la france parce que la france
c'est un pays ennemi et que n'a pas eue
jamais dans le passé n'a pas ingéré
s'initier dans le nous affairer
intérieur et que les iraniens voient la
france d'un bon oeil
monsieur l'ambassadeur quelles mesures
concrètes
pensez vous que la france pourrait
prendre si elle accepter cette médiation
entre l'iran et les états unis
monsieur comme nous avons interrompu
notre relation diplomatique avec les
états unis
alors la france favoriser et plus
olivier de conseiller monsieur cratère
de ne pas toujours nous menacer et que
de faire 2
d'avoir eu l'impression que c'est de
faire un geste qui soit concret ça veut
dire que la france est habilité de
conseillers en sucre était de ne pas
faire le dicta mais seulement nos jours
de la question on doit réserver le mal à
la racine et auquel cas vous pensez que
l' affaire des otages pourraient être
réglés de cette façon écoutez monsieur
la fed les otages ne concerne pas le
gouvernement
j'espère que si si mais cette médiation
vient cet ouvrage d'un espace politique
aura lieu le climat d'une autre
parlement va changer l'atmosphère nous
on va changer dans l'avenir on peut
penser qu'à partir du moment où cette
médiation ray lieu les choses pourraient
évoluer favori la seule chose que je
pense parce que il n'y a pas d'autre
solution
quelle solution que veulent les états
unis où vont les états unis l'équipe
actuelle au pouvoir est elle toujours en
mesure d'assurer commandites en
franglais le leadership de l'occident
l'ex président richard nixon qui vient
de publier un livre d'après guerre est
très sévère à l'égard des dirigeants
américains actuels en tout cas s'il est
quelqu'un qui est en mesure de parler en
connaissance de cause de ce qu'est la
politique américaine de ce qu'elle veut
c'est bien lui
monsieur dixon sera demain ici l'invité
d'antenne 2010 où il répondra aux
questions de jean pierre elkabbach
paul nahon et de notre confrère jean
françois revel directeur de l'express
l'état du président tito et plus en plus
grave le dernier bulletin de santé
souligne avec insistance le caractère
préoccupant de l'hémorragie interne qui
se poursuit en dépit des mesures prises
par les médecins ceux-ci d'autre part
sont inquiets de la lésions du foie
récemment apparues et de la persistance
de la pneumonie et de la forte fièvre
c'est une très longue
une très dure réguler france au large de
l'île de batz les opérations
préparatoires au colmatage de la brèche
du cargo tanio qui a coulé le mois
dernier avec dix mille tonnes de pétrole
dans ces plans devaient commencer ce
matin par 87 mètres de fond le navire de
soutien interrompu trois devaient mettre
à l'eau deux mini sous marin avec pour
but de repérer les fuites du tanio grâce
à un système vidéo
les vents soufflant en rafales jusqu'à
100 kilomètres à l'heure sur la zone du
naufrage du tanio et l'interview pris
dans cette tempête a dû en être gagner
le port il attendra pour repartir que
les vents ce terme
monsieur mitterrand premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste était aujourd'hui
l'invité de nos confrères d'europe
numéro un dans leur émission le club de
la presse il y à aborder entre autres
thèmes
le différend entre la majorité de son
parti le parti socialiste et monsieur
michel rocard voici un extrait de ce
qu'il est un parti qui aujourd'hui le
plus important de la gauche française
si l'on voulait parler stricto sensu le
plus important de la vie nationale
quand je dis stricto sensu c'est parce
qu'une comparaison difficile avec l'udf
qui est un conglomérat de formations
différentes
ce parti à la veille peut-être d'occuper
les principales responsabilités du
pouvoir
ce parti là il faut bien qu'ils
disposent de quelles fins de préférence
le premier des siens capable de
rassembler de préserver l'unité
d'accroître l'audience de tous est de
maintenir la ligne politique choisie
voilà mon rôle
le comité central du rpr qui s'est
réunie aujourd'hui à paris a adopté une
motion dans laquelle elle renouvelle son
attachement à la participation et où il
rappelle que dès 1977 le rpr l'avait
défini cette participation comme un
ensemble concernant à la fois la
participation bénéfices au capital et à
l'élaboration par toutes les catégories
personnel des décisions concernant la
vie des entreprises et leur devenir
le comité central considère d'autres
parcs doit être reconnue par la voie
législative
un droit d'expression des salariés sur
l'organisation et l'exécution de leur
travail et le comité central fait
confiance au groupe parlementaire rpr
pour que ce débat fondamental soit menée
à bien
daniel brême assister aux travaux est-ce
qu'on a parlé
seulement de cela c'est à dire seulement
de la participation aussi d'autres
fausses bouthéon public c'est vrai on
n'a parlé que de la participation en
privé cette autre chose
dire que nous n'avons pas pensé à la
sphère peyrefitte m'a dit un membre du
comité central serait mentir mais
jacques chirac nous avait mis en garde
et nous l'avons écouté alors il a ajouté
de toute façon cette affaire se règle
sans que nous ayons à y mettre les mains
et de toute façon elle ne doit pas faire
oublier les autres alors l'insistance
mise quelques instants après par bernard
pense le secrétaire général du rpr pour
convaincre les journalistes que ce
comité central avait été exemplaire
parce qu'il n'avait parlé que des
problèmes concrets qui intéresse les
français
évidemment n'était pas elle non plus
fortuite comment expliquez-vous ce
public que ce silence
mais côté jacques chirac s'est servie de
l'agitation actuelle
c'était de bonne guerre pour resserrer
les rangs autour de lui pour éviter que
le cas échéant on évoque la sphère de
michel aulas candidature de michel debré
pardo et également pour se placer hors
de la mêlée et même en donneur de leçons
et il a affirmé sur un ton gaullien
il est intolérable à l'heure où la paix
la sécurité la prospérité sont si
menacée que la société politique se
plaisent à sombrer dans l'irréalité la
discorde et l'agitation sonore ajoutant
tout cela ne nous concerne pas un
sursaut s'impose de la part de ceux qui
revendiquent la haute mission de guider
le pays
mais ce n'est pas tout car jacques
chirac l'occasion était trop belle il en
a profité pour s'engager lui un e
déroger ni à la rigueur ni à lonay
thénia la dignité dans le grand débat
politique qui va s'ouvrir
sous-entendu une vraie profession de foi
d'un vrai candidat ou aux élections
présidentielles depuis 48 heures en
afrique australe l'ardesi le zimbabwe
forme un état indépendant et vous avez
vu sur vos écrans
les cérémonies d'indépendance en
présence de charles prince de galles
l'équipe dirigeante du zimbabwe est à
très forte proportion de noirs
est-ce que cela ne va pas devenir une
tentation pour la population noire qui
vident
le pays immédiatement voisins du
zimbabwe c'est à dire l'union
sud-africaine où vous le savez jusqu'à
présent au contraire le pouvoir est
totalement aux mains des blancs sans
parler de la politique de ségrégation
raciale qui est un dogme
le reportage de philippe chatenet jean
rey se propose de répondre à cette
interrogation
c'est dans les cités noir de l'afrique
du sud comme ici à soweto que la
conquête du pouvoir par les noirs en
rhodésie a eu le plus grand impact
soweto c'est une immense ville dortoir
aux portes de johannesbourg où vivent un
million deux cent et noir c'est ici en
juin 1976 qu'ont éclaté les pires
émeutes raciales qui ait jamais connue
l'afrique du sud des centaines de morts
et de blessés des millions de
destruction depuis soweto est devenu un
symbole aux yeux du monde entier de la
lutte des noirs contre la part d'un saut
et au est en fait une conséquence de
l'apartheid
cette politique de séparation rigoureuse
des races et des ethnies appliquée par
le gouvernement blanc depuis 30 ans
elle s'appelle themba ningen à 45 ans qu
en deux à johannesbourg à elle seule
elle fit vivre toute sa famille c'est à
dire son mari et leurs enfants une
famille unie croyantes ou avant de
manger on remercie
et vous
son mari est invalide ses enfants vont à
l'école l'aîné et chômeurs la grande
peur de la famille c'est que si la mère
personnes en emploi toute la famille
risque de perdre le droit de vivre à
soweto et on peut les obliger à aller
s'établir dans un bantoustan c'est à
dire le territoire l'état de leur tribu
et cela bien qu'il soit né à soweto
qu'ils aient vécu toute leur vie ici
les revendications des noirs de soweto
s'exprime à travers ses toiles et le
docteur une hta tomota n'at il est le
président du conseil 10 10 le plus
respecté le plus influent dignitaire de
soweto
il se dit modéré mais il a déjà été
arrêté plusieurs fois pour ses activités
politiques
rien n'a changé depuis les émeutes de
1976 rien de fondamental nous avons
entendu des discours sur la nécessité de
réforme mais pour ce qui est du vrai
changement que nous voulons nous les
noirs
rien n'a pour les noirs les clés profond
des événements du zimbabwe et que les
jeunes militants nous disent à nous les
vieux les modérés qui ne pourra y avoir
de changement ici sans effusion aulas
maurice pop hip hop d'élise nos proches
nos rêves en amène djendjen blatier il y
a plus de changements maintenant que
dans toute l'histoire de l'afrique du
sud dans certains domaines il est vrai
les réformes n'ont pas été aussi
spectaculaire que les gens pressés leur
ai souhaité il apparaît en premier
ministre de décider de la rapidité du
changement
s'il va trop vite le danger existe qu'il
perde l'appui des électeurs s'il va trop
lentement processus révolutionnaire
pourrait se déclencher riz alors la
solution est entre les deux mais le but
doit toujours être de faire changer les
choses d'une manière
significative aussi rapidement que
possible
cette école est un exemple de
l'ambiguïté de la situation actuelle en
afrique du sud
faut-il dire c'était que les petites et
les vieilles elle n'a même pas
l'électricité
ou faut-il dire elle existe et envoyer
ses enfants ne coûte pas cher et on y
apprend bien racontée par exemple en
anglais et en cause à la langue tribal
de ses enfants
en fait ce sont les enfants de soweto
qui devront choisir entre les modérés
qui veulent négocier un meilleur partage
du pouvoir avec les blancs et les jeunes
militants pour qui seule la violence
plein de même changement
dans une large mesure leur réponse
dépendra de ce que les blancs seront
prêts à leur céder sans y être
contraints comme l'ont été au bout de
sept ans de guerre
les blancs rhodésie aujourd'hui de plus
en plus de sud africains savent que leur
pays devra changer ou mauvais
j'avais un groove vous êtes britannique
vous êtes correspondant permanent du
times à paris vous connaissez bien
commonwealth vous venez de voir le
reportage
alors est ce qu'à votre avis ce qui
vient de se passer en rhodésie zimbabwe
ne va pas amener en union sud africaine
est presque nous avons vu une sorte de
déstabilisation dans une partie
extrêmement importante pour l'avenir de
la planète
oui il est évident que non seulement un
nouvel état est né il ya deux jours en
rhodésie mais aussi je dirais que
l'afrique du sud de ce fait est devenu
le seul pays du continent africain où
l'homme noir est en état de
subordination légale à l'homme blanc et
c'est une situation qui évidemment ne
pourra pas continuer éternellement
il est certain que ce qui s'est passé en
rhodésie est à la fois à un avis hein
et en même temps une espérance je dirais
que c'est âme
c'est un avis dans le sens où si le co
le gouvernement sud-africain n'évolue
pas
graduellement vers une plus grande
participation une participation puisque
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure les noirs
ne participent pas du tout au
gouvernement mais une plus grande
participation une participation au
gouvernement
il y a évidemment un risque de
déstabilisation de deux guerres civiles
comme il y en a eu en rhodésie mais
c'est en fait la rhodésie ou le zimbabwe
pour l'appeler par son nouveau nom et
une espérance car après sept ans d'une
guerre civile qui a fait 25 mille
victimes n'est ce pas est un million de
réfugiés des destructions sans nombre on
est revenu à une table de conférence et
on a décidé de faire un compromis qui se
solde par un gouvernement pacifique avec
un leader qui était connue autrefois
pour ses idées marxistes ronchinoises un
extrémiste le leader de la principale
guérilla
alors c'est là quand même un espoir j'en
étais encore une question est ce que le
gouvernement sud africain devant cet
état de fait ne va pas tenter
d'appliquer la fameuse formule
prévenir vaut mieux que guérir je crois
que le gouvernement sud africain comme
nous l'avons vu dans ce reportage a déjà
commencé
le faire et que ce qui s'est passé en
rhodésie avec les élections où ils
avaient misé sur une victoire de
l'évêque nous aurait ou a le le noir je
m'explique je le dire mes collaborateurs
des blancs si vous voulez qui a été
complètement balayées laura combat
contre quand même appris une leçon aux à
ceux qui ne voulaient rien céder et je
crois que monsieur botha l'actuel
ministre sud africain en tirera tous les
enseignements pour pousser les éléments
les plus durs d à d african vers une
politique plus souple et plus élastique
qui donne au noir une plus grande
participation à faire vous êtes donc
d'un optimisme raisonné je suis d'un
optimisme raisonné n'est pas chef je
l'espère irait irraisonnables ou
déraisonnable
merci les soins de beauté c'est un art
une technique et une industrie une
industrie considérable le chiffre
d'affaires de l'activité dans l'ensemble
du monde vient aussitôt après celui des
industries de l'acier
d'où ces états généraux d'esthétique
appliquée qui s'est éteinte à versailles
et qui réunissent plus de 5000
esthéticienne venus du monde entier
qu'est ce qui amène des femmes à se
maquiller la recherche de la beauté bien
sûr et le désir de paraître et d'essayer
de rester toujours avec cet avis est
très large
alors l intrus qui sont sortis dans ma
ville tant à dire au lieu de faire
élever son visage elle l'a abaissée à
moi je vais travailler à reconstruire a
élevé
et vous et ça va me permettre pour faire
ensuite les ans au moins
creusée sur l'image
le côté pour les 150 exposants de ce
congrès la beauté ne peut se concevoir
qu'avec l'attirail de poudre massage
onguents tous ceux qui exalte l'image
traditionnelle de la femme objet dont on
connaît le seul souci reste est jeune en
point de vue nouveautés on peut pas
parler de nouveauté réel la seule chose
qu'on peut dire c'est que la motivation
essentielle des soins fait dans le cas
de cette union professionnelle est
essentiellement axé contre le
vieillissement ou la prévention si vous
voulez du bief le rajeunissement pas
tout à fait non peut pas dire qu'on
rajeunisse on peut simplement dire qu'on
peut prévenir dans une certaine mesure
le vieillissement
un des thèmes débattus au cours du
congrès le contentieux entre les
esthéticiennes et les masseurs
kinésithérapeutes qui craignent de voir
grignoter leur prérogative
professionnels
ils y ont essayé par le truchement d'une
loi de se défendre
ils ont fait de cette profession
extraordinaire esthéticienne les lui le
kinésithérapeute qui travaillent avec
les médecins sur ordonnance médicale
si avec a pas de logique alors
l'esthéticienne c'est la beauté j'ai
quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'est mon
chien la corde mais par contre ça peut
être complémentaire
il y a une finalité dans toute la chose
kinésithérapeute une fois qu'il a
terminée
l'esthéticienne que le relais et
s'occupe de la beauté corporelle de
l'hygiène corporelle de la salle
je
s'intéresse plus au préalable alors le
maquillage c'est aux normes et ce qu'ils
veulent aborder tout le monde il est à
la portée de ceux et celles qui veulent
apprendre mais il est certain que si on
n'a pas le sens du dessin et de
l'architecturé doit faire des efforts
mathias et pas de la couleur
de maquillage et de l'architecturé
on verra peut-être bientôt des médecins
dans les rues des grandes villes
manifesté pendant que leurs cabinets
seront fermés pour cause de grève
c'est en tout cas ce qu ils ont envisagé
aujourd'hui lors de l'assemblée générale
de la confédération des syndicats
médicaux qui représentent 75 % des
praticiens français sport la principale
épreuve d'aujourd'hui à longchamp le
prix n'a été remporté par jules césar à
50 contre 1 quant au tiercé le prix de
notre confrère paris turf
voici l'arrivée premier d'hôtel le 12
qui restait déjà sur une victoire au
mois de mars
il appartient à monsieur courtois et il
était monté par jérôme deuxième le 9
jadis troisième le 3 go sport 12 9 3
rien des multiples de trois commentaires
le pire et brosse une course attire ces
qui se déroule sur une courte distance
1950 mètres et dans un terrain léger ça
va vite très vite dans le bas de la
descente par exemple se trouvent les
choux actuellement la vitesse de pointe
atteint 65 kilomètres à l'heure et
lorsque le peut-on se compose de 23
chevaux très groupée il est bien
difficile de se dégager quand on est
enfermé au milieu c'est ce qui est
arrivé à d'orbec serge girly son
apprenti n'a pas pu le sortir à temps
pour prétendre disputer l'arrivée
au début de la ligne droite gran mogol
est devant avec total gros porc super
flight les taloches al dik north and
dreams et nara blue qui vient à
l'extérieur un mailing droite gran mogol
résiste toujours à l'attack dodo talent
mais les 57 kg et demi qu'ils portent
sur les épaules commence à se faire
sentir
jacques dickner scène dream nara blue et
little love accélère l'alluré total qui
décidément est dans un bon jour se fait
pardonner ces dernières contre
performances et garder l'avantagé
jusqu'au bout mais la lutte est sévère
le jockey de jeannes bic en a d'ailleurs
perdu sa toque en bonne position pendant
tout le parcours jal dit des gros porcs
prendront les deuxième et troisième
places
à la surprise générale et pour le plus
grand bien des parieurs car grâce à eux
le tiercé 12 9 3 rapporte dans l'ordre
pour 526 1850 de francs 50 et dans le
désordre pour 5 francs 3516 francs 50
bernard hinault a remporté aujourd'hui
liège bastogne liège qu'il avait déjà
gagné il y a trois ans mais aujourd'hui
il l'a fait d'une manière époustouflante
avec plus de neuf minutes d'avancé sur
son suivant immédiat le néerlandais
hennie kuiper l'écart entre les deux
hommes représentent la différence la
plus grande enregistré depuis de très
très longues années
à l'arrivée d'une course classique bref
comme ça fait longtemps attendre la
victoire de bernard hinault n'en a été
que plus avec nos compliments et le
commentaire de jean paul ollivier voici
bernard hinault vexé de sa défaite face
à saronni dans la flèche wallonne jeudi
dernier le breton d'yffiniac a répliqué
dans un sursaut d'orgueil de la façon la
plus éclatante à 80 kilomètres de
l'arrivée
il est parti dès lors le chronomètre
s'est emballée hinault par un travail de
sape et est en train de gagner par ko
dans des conditions atmosphériques
effroyable il a neigé
il a plu il faisait froid sarni
abandonnait et hino superbe ne concédait
pas un pouce de terrain à des
adversaires devenu qui m'aurait tels que
y perd duclos-lassalle de wolf peters
lui berline ou baddou
ne dites surtout jamais à hinault qu'il
a été battu sur sa valeur car la course
suivante il vous réserve une revanche
face à face au faso qui est aussi celle
du tour de lombardie l'an dernier
hinault atteint attend 120 quiétude le
tour d'italie sans renier moser ont
beaucoup de soucis à se faire
en tout cas il est bien parti pour
remporter au mois de juin juillet son
troisième tour de france
alors des deux roues sans moteur venons
en aux deux roues à moteur 24 heures
motocyclistes au mans on attendait une
honda c'est ce qui s'est passé mais ce
n'est pas celle des favoris des oiseaux
marins qui ont dû abandonner ce matin
accidents matériels bris de vilebrequin
les vainqueurs sont wano et fontang
celui ci étant un pilote de grand prix
ils ont couvertes de 3400 km en 24
heures c'est à dire qu'ils ont roulé à
plus de 133 de moyenne deuxième père et
jbod 80 km de distance derrière eux sur
suzuki la semaine frère un pic à la
voile vient de se dérouler hier et c'est
l'une des manifestations les plus
importantes de l'année dans ce domaine
elle réunissait comme d'habitude de
toutes les cseries olympique de dérive
air depuis les fines jusqu'au sonic un
commentaire sur cette épreuve
internationale par gilles que année
depuis quelques années le mot voilée
dans l'opinion publique synonyme de
course autour du monde et de
transatlantic eric tabarly et le sportif
français le plus populaire mais du
dériveur on ignore tout ou presque
et pourtant cette semaine à hier s'est
déroulée une compétition réunissant les
meilleurs équipages du monde au mont du
dériveur et des dérivés olympiques c'est
une des deux grandes classiques au monde
il ya deux grandes épreuves de voix qui
réunissent toutes les séries olympiques
la semaine de guy dans les membranes
dans nord de l'allemagne et la semaine
denière 29 nation 300 concurrence et de
grands rassemblements
dériveur olympique le yacht-club
d'hyères qui organise ces compétitions
est un club comme il en existe des
milliers en france et témoigne de la
vitalité souvent ignorée du yachting
léger français on se souvient parce qu
il s'illustrait rocourt de régates
olympique des frères pajot de serge
maury mais sait-on que nous avons
aujourd'hui d'autres champions de la
même valeur aussi bon marin que tabarly
riguidel ou kersauson et qui malgré tous
n'ont pas la même notoriété
et vous savez qu'une coupe du monde de
voile un peu dans le style de ce qui se
fait en ski avec des classements
individuels bon deux français ont gagné
en 4 70 sedan dernier et en soling ben
ouais t'as fait second flemme de
schumann et la france a gagné la coupe
du monde par équipes donc disons que
nous sommes au top niveau le c'était
relativement facile d'y parvenir c'est
beaucoup plus dur du respect sur 1980
devant être une année olympique
cette semaine de hyères prenait un
relief particulier les meilleurs
équipages étrangers avaient fait le
déplacement une répétition générale en
quelque sorte les menaces de boycottage
se précisant les jeux étaient au centre
de beaucoup de conversations soit pour
le regretté soit pour faire preuve de
lucidité comme le fait thierry poiret
champion du monde de flying dutchman en
1979 avec marc goua des jeux
moi j'ai pris une position
personnel en disant que les jeux en fait
sur une compétition qu on doit réussir
l'exploit
essayons de vaincre mais pour quelle
victoire
et bien afin de répondre à cette
question et pour que vous puissiez
suivre les grands moments de cette
aventure une autre équipe celle
d'antenne 2 à a suivi les athées liste
jacques ertaud et dominique martial vous
présenteront demain soir à 20h35 leurs
émissions réponse
le ton est bien demain lundi ciel
variable est températures fraîches du
nord et ne reste aux alpes et au jura
éclaircies pluie et neige à basse
altitude alterneront baisse des
températures gelée blanche au lever du
jour dans les régions les plus
continentale et sur les régions
méditerranéennes temps relativement
frais et celle dégagée par le mistral et
la tramontane les enverra tueur minimale
baisseront mais les températures
maximales seront plutôt en légère hausse
par rapport à celle de georges lors
lagence pour les économies d'énergie
vous recommande de maintenir vos
installations de chauffage à l'arrêt si
vous avez été le littoral languedocien
la provence la côte d'azur la corse où
le roussillon à une altitude inférieure
à 350 mètres ailleurs vous pourrez
remettre de chauffage en route mais
pensez surtout à le limiter à 19 degrés
notre religion est terminée à 23h rights
vous donnera les dernières informations
et demain vous retrouverez à nos
diverses éditions au présentateur
habituel je vous rappelle antenne de
midi tout spécialement avec comme invité
monsieur richard nixon
bonsoir